mr president
excellencies ladies and gentlemen what
do we need
to make the case for biodiversity loud
and clear
figures for years scientists have
provided us with the most striking
figures
of spacing species at risk of
disappearing
but it was not enough pictures
for years photographers and documentary
makers
have provided us with moving and
breathtaking visuals
of species at risk of disappearing
but it was not enough do we need
to be affected directly and massively in
our life
like a pandemic a world pandemic
locking us in at home with no
possibility to travel
a pandemic caused by a zoonotic disease
mr president excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
isn't it telling that it is precisely
such a pandemic that prevents us from
meeting
in person for this united nations
biodiversity summit
that it is a pandemic that made it
necessary to postpone the cup 15 in
kunming
from october 2020 to the second half of
21.
dear friends we have all the information
needed to understand
climate change and biodiversity loss are
happening before our eyes
and they reinforce each other we need
to stop this loop of doom
that is driving me as president of the
european commission
after just 11 days in office i presented
the european green deal it is our vision
and roadmap to making europe the first
climate neutral continent by 2050.
to achieve this we set out 50 actions
for 2050.
in march we proposed the first ever
continental climate law
and then the pandemic came into our
lives
now should we stop our course
because of the pandemic of course not
and this is why we also adopted our eu
biodiversity strategy for 2030 in may
2020 the biodiversity strategy tackles
the key drivers
of biodiversity loss unsustainable use
of land and sea
exploitation of natural resources
pollution
and global warming the strategy proposes
legal obligations targets and actions
to restore damage ecosystems and rivers
to improve the health of eu protected
habitats and species
and to bring back pollinators to
agricultural lands
but also to green our cities to enhance
organic farming
and to improve the health of european
forests
just to name a few
biodiversity is much more than only
nature protection the link with our food
system is so strong
that we adopted our farm to fork
strategy in parallel
the same day the two are mutually
reinforcing
today we are calling on everyone who is
willing to join our action
to halt biodiversity loss
the community of those who want to move
forward
is becoming bigger and stronger every
day
development and humanitarian
organizations
companies and cities
youth and faith organizations
and of course all countries and regions
around the world who want to address
biodiversity loss this
is really why we are joining forces
today
to team up and provide determined
leadership
our aim is a new global biodiversity
framework in kunming next year
we want global rules that are clear
measurable
that allow us to hold each other to
account
and above all rules that will protect
species
and strengthen our resilience and our
well-being
let us make this our common mission
you can count on my commitment thank you